we're used to the idea of sex being used
to sell stuff it happens all the time
often it's used to sell cars or perfumes
or even less substantial things like ice
creams making use of another human being
sexuality to generate an enthusiasm for
consumer products seems a pretty
depressing manoeuvre demeaning as much
to buyers and producers but before we
despair of our shallowness let's go back
a few centuries to consider the
educational theories of one of the
greatest Renaissance Italian
philosophers marsilii oficina vicino was
unfazed by our tendencies to be
interested in sex this was he thought
simply an inevitable consequence of our
bodily nature which dictates but our
initial interest in things will almost
invariably spring from our sexual and
sensory faculties now the reason for
Tina was undisturbed by this is that
this wasn't in his eyes the end of the
story though our interest in things may
well begin at the sexual level this is
merely the starting point the destiny of
our interest is to move on to a stage of
higher engagement that Fujino called
love and from there we may ascend to a
third stage the longing and capacity to
understand
so our interests are naturally inclined
if well tended to follow a path from sex
to love to intellectual engagement and
this holds true for an interest in
people and virtues and even in abstract
ideas patina was above all else an
educator that is he thought profoundly
about how people learn and how one can
best teach people and so he concluded
that the best way to get an idea into
someone's mind is not to try at once
coldly to engage their reason it is
first to reach them via their senses and
in particular via their interest in sex
[Music]
Pacino was employed by the great
Renaissance patron and Statesman Lorenzo
de Medici both were desperate to educate
as many people as possible in Florence
to be wise and good using the lessons of
antiquity and Christianity and they
wanted to use art to do this launching
what was in effect a giant ad campaign
for the highest goals Pacino's ideas
lent this educational program a unique
angle vitinho proposed that the artist
Lorenzo was employing should devote
themselves to painting successions of
beautiful or plain sexy
we may have often been struck by how
many attractive people there are in
Renaissance art this is no coincidence
this is deliberate consequence of fur
chinos educational theories artists
guided by the Philosopher's were
commissioned to use sex to sell but sell
the highest things like piety virtue and
modesty commitment to the intellect and
devotion to scholarship
it's a maneuver we've come to forget in
our own times we still use sacks but
only ever to sell the lowest things and
when it comes to the highest things we
deem them above the grubby task of being
sold and therefore they languish with
Patino's lessons in mind we should be
more strategic we should recognize that
there's nothing wrong with using sex to
film so long as what we're selling
happens to be Noble indeed selling
higher things sex is a generous act that
graciously acknowledges how our minds
really work we cannot or should not be
expected to learn without our senses
first having men litter we just have to
make sure we're selling the right thing
not cars for confectionery but perhaps
things like a channel devoted to wisdom
and philosophy Pacino would have
approved if you liked our films take a
look at our shop the School of Life comm
forward slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you